hey everyone thank you for coming this
afternoon I guess we're just gone
halfway through our conference
I'm Lewistown and Perry so today I'm
gonna be talking to you about scaling
micro services with message queue start
my core and keeping at ease so if you
want to contact me I'd recommend using
Twitter you can message me on there or
just grab me after here or I'll be here
all week
so NDC means so much to me it was the
first conference I went to I gave a
lightning talk yesterday about it and
and help me find my love of development
again so it's amazing that I'm here
today I'm so happy to be here and I
really hope that I can share with you
some of the things I've learned in the
last couple of years as well as you have
other speakers I've given to me and on
that note and there's a couple of
speakers who I've really admire for
making making people aware of issues
within our industry so just to start
mental health I suffered from depression
and it still I'm still trying to manage
it occasionally I am but equally come in
to conferences a kind of can be a big
daunting thing so if you do need to talk
to someone because a lot of people have
helped me out by being able to talk to
them if you need some help just again
give me a shape so I'm not know as well
please take photos because like I said
it's a six track conference three days
you're going to learn so much and if his
things that interest you please take
photos to remember so yeah I work for
this company now alone kubernetes so
I've now become a trainer so we do two
or three day workshops in the public and
private sector and two years ago I
wouldn't have thought that I would be in
that space but that's where I've ended
up because originally I was a.net
developer for him through I been working
for I yeah I've been contracting for
about 10 years now within the industry
and then I fell in love with dotnet core
I had a MacBook with I call it Windows
in disguise because her the business I
was in they said you need to have a
MacBook and so I just got parallels and
I put windows in it to feel safe again
but then I started using dotnet core to
see how I could use my MacBook
so on that as well I'm going to the
layout of his talks gonna be a little
bit different so I'm just gonna give
some tips because these are my tips so
I'd like to call them alpha rock or tips
because no one's going to hear this
after this so it's okay this isn't
anything associated with flow and Kuban
at ease this is how I've got to a stage
where I could start training so first of
all just containers this is where it all
starts and we're going to be talking
about an orchestrated a keepin a tease
but I got I became interested in
containers because of a way that we can
use them to manage our work I got so fed
up of having to find a way to deploy
something a hands me of a hand being
deployed for the last three months and
then the person who deployed at last
they left the business two months ago
and I didn't know what I was going to do
so as leaning towards containers just to
have this kind of state and that I could
work with so I went to a well-known
search engine and then I started looking
at now some containers darker what's
this and it all just ended up being on
Linux Linux Linux and it's like no I'm
Windows I don't know that not interested
but then I found this
Sir Elton Stillman he's got a book
called dagger on Windows this is a book
I read this within two days and then it
got me up to speed straight away so this
is all windows-based if they take Scott
Hanselman had an MVC project in 2011 I
called no dinner and so they put that
into a container and it's by full gig in
size which isn't ideal but then they
used a strangler pattern to be able to
take things apart so on that point as
well Elton's gonna be here tomorrow and
he's gonna be talking about what is just
why there's a service mat and that's in
room 5 so I also run a meetup in Wales
called Clio native Wales and I run it
with a salmon who's here today and also
a chap called
Alex so for Halloween last year this was
his idea of a service mesh so hopefully
you'll be able to know a little bit more
as well it is tomorrow so the other
thing I just want to make people aware
of is Microsoft love Linux and so within
kubernetes Microsoft are helping out so
much on the Linux so they've got a chap
called Brandon burns who is one of the
founders of coop laddies is now with
Microsoft there's a huge team there and
they offer also offer
things such as ham and draft to the CN
CF which we'll come to in a moment but I
want it now I get it I get if you're on
Windows and Kiba now uses its the next
thing I get it you want it now now I'm
not comfortable enough to come on stage
and show you keeping ideas on Windows
and be confident enough to give you a
live demo and it all working because
I've got enough pain in my life but
later on I'll give you a show you a
couple of diagrams and I can show you
how we can actually process some window
workloads within containers at the
moment within humanities so oh and this
chat Sam Newman great great guy and yeah
you don't have to run cuban at ease so
always think about as well i'm not going
to have arguments about you should be
using keep an eye geez everyone's
different it's fine it's just nice to
know what the options are available so
am i yeah i've also been quite ill today
so I only just got in my hotel room 10
minutes ago and my voice is usually a
little bit higher than this and so I
don't know if this has happened already
in conference finger but has anyone had
to contain a slide yet there's anyone
seen one this week call okay you can
take that off a card you've done that
one that's cool so this is what
containers is shown as and it's been
shown for a while and people send
they're bored of this so I got a
different idea as to what container is
for me so does anyone watch Rick and
Morty here can I see it we got some
hands yes we got hands we've got
participation that's it so this is what
I think containers are more like so does
anyone know who this is
it's I think I heard someone sings music
yeah yeah yeah well yes so what happens
is that when they have a job to do they
press a button
he appears he'll do the job and then he
dies just doesn't one drop now when with
spoiler alerts when they try to do
multiple jobs it all goes to chaos it's
the same with containers just focus on
simple things and doing them quickly and
right so CN CF it's kind native
computing foundation they're an open
source organization and if you look here
at the landscape elder C&C after i/o
they'll show you everything that's
available so all the projects that are
open sourced there so so I know if
there's just so much stuff but it's a
really useful tool because when you hear
buzzwords when you hear this
should not sleep as was when you see
when you hear products and you just
trying to understand what they are and
duvet do you need them do you require
them either enniaa for alternatives and
this is a great resource so that you can
click on how and then you can see other
options other than a helm so I
definitely recommend that they also have
this trail map so this trail map is
really good at understanding how to
become cloud native so the idea is is
that you start on point one and you work
your way down the trail so at point one
we do have a containerization there we
go there so containerization so again
this is a key point just do containers
right and then also set up a CI CD
pipeline as well so that we can automate
builds and then you can look towards
orchestrators another tip is learned
back so there's a great resource by a
chap called Ben Hall called cutter coder
so most of the things that you see
within CN CF you're probably going to
find on CAD coder as well so this he
spins up VMs in the cloud somewhere else
and allows you to jump in in your
browser without having to install any
dependencies and then you can start you
can start playing with products and
that's the concept of learn back instead
of having to learn and install
everything and then just hit all the
bugs and everything else it'll give you
a scenario where you can build something
and then you can work your way back from
so my last tip as well is just learn
simple things for hard way I went in a
high level and then I had to keep
knocking back down a level so on that
point there's this trap in meal I think
and he's got a book called learn bash
for hard way he recommended to use this
URL to purchase it if you're interested
and it's a great so I used to commute to
Bristol every day and so I had an hour
on the train and so I could do this all
on my laptop without an internet
connection and that allowed me I can do
so many more things now that I wasn't
aware of before I was a great dev of
wool or I should not say I was a great
Dave I've there's some people in a room
that Novell has to like um but I was I
was good at certain things and then I
was terrified to have to learn back and
go and learn and have a stack I've
always been scared to go to driver
because I'm like well I'm Microsoft but
I know this this is this is my domain
but I've actually found out that if you
learn stuff it's actually kind of
similar everywhere
if you're here you I'm sure you've got
quite a good ability so it's and it's
really interesting when you find out how
to do other well I find it interesting
anyway we've have a technology so that's
the cover of the book so I will stop
giving tips now I just wanted to give up
because that's the stuff I wish I heard
on day one when I started my queue
bananas adventure so now we're going to
go into the slides so I'm going to talk
a little bit about Cuban at ease and
scalability and why it's of interest to
us after that we're going to have a
little bit of a demo so again it's there
might be some audience participation but
I'm going to try and yeah oh and
actually this demo I just run it half an
hour ago to film it so because you know
if it goes wrong I can show you the
video and the video went wrong and
that's a cluster I'm going to be using
so sit tight because I don't know what's
going to happen so it's good ability and
robustness here we go
so in life we like to purchase things so
all of a sudden the new product comes
out and what happens next is is that
comes available at 5 p.m. or 6 p.m. and
so throughout the day we don't have any
traffic and then we got a huge spike
there so how do you deal with so much
traffic so we have the back end in the
front end so the back end is usually our
REST API and then we'd have different
fit so we'd have browsers and we'd have
other devices and they could connect to
our back-end API so planning for launch
so I'd like to introduce you to Chris
and his cut to Dan and so what happen is
is that vaso front-end web application
and our back-end API and what we've said
is is actually we want to have four
back-end API so to do that we need to be
able to network between them so we have
put something in place that we call a
load balancer now we'd also do the same
thing on a front-end so that we can have
multiple instances of friends on the
backend running and we don't have to
worry about where the traffic is being
directed to so performance tests let's
have a quick go out performance test so
our front-end application is stateless
and we have a limit of a thousand
requests a second our back-end is
stateless and it also has a limit of
250 requests per assignment so it's a
ratio of 1 to 4 so let's get ready for
this so let's think again there's finger
if your favorite finger you want to
purchase next it's become available at
6:00 p.m. and all right leave it say
that you're you're in the office and you
have one who's trying to manage this so
what we've got is is that we got four
front ends and four back ends now that's
not ideal already because we know about
the front end can handle a thousand each
but back end can only handle 250 each so
when traffic's it starts to overload
some of back ends they start going
offline and when they go offline it's
not really helping you issue by just
sending everything else at to the other
ones and they're just like well I got
too much to do it's not gonna work and
then it just all goes but then what you
do is is that you here as someone
someone up in a business did call you
directly and say the site's down
everything's crashing so you just ask
alt some more allowed some more so you
add four more and then everything comes
back up online but the issue is that's
too little too late we've had have a
manual intervention to be able to do
that so and now we've just missed the
peak demand of it as well so we've
missed a great opportunity so let's have
a look at this case set then where we
don't just have one Chris but we have
multiple Chris's and downs and actually
the websites just can't handle it is too
much traffic and then all of a sudden
everything just starts crashing and then
at that point this game over man game
over it's it doesn't matter so I'm sure
you're thinking as a nice story to us
but how do we know we know how to do
scaling and so I think someone said that
and I don't it might be from some
organization but maybe like this
organization which so there's everyone
know when prime Deus or is no
roundabouts so you kind of think that
the infrastructure would be ready well
the only thing that was scaling here was
just for news articles just lots more
news articles become unavailable saying
that they can't be scale so they report
was the retailer that didn't have enough
servers to handle the traffic source for
the day and Amazon had to manually add
servers to address the issue and fail to
add them fast enough
so how could we improve s or what could
you improve so we could have automatic
scaling could we also have decoupling of
scaling so in this example we've got a
ratio of 1 to 4 so we got to front-end
web apps and we've got free to because 8
backends so it's a wonderful ratio so if
we increase it then can we also scale
that to keep the ratio to 1 to 4 and
then if we actually say to ourselves
we're using up too much resource we
could say we want to have it as a 1 to 2
ratio and then it updates automatically
can we also D couple our failures so
here's our user again and we've got a
document that we've put into the system
and then it gets processed somewhere in
the backend and it's all done great good
job but what happens when we don't have
a back-end document for stays there or
does it just collect at that point so
what if we just had a message broke of
it so the user that we have goes through
a web site and then sends a couple of
messages to us and in turn they get sent
to the message queue and then when it's
available the backend can pick it up and
process accordingly so scalenes
apparently we've done it so we can now
say that we've got four fronts and four
back and then we can scale to one it's
great we can handle and we can also no
handle failures so if a back-end isn't
available then yeah it will just seen a
message queue so what about automatic
scaling so this is where the orchestra
just come into play so keep an eye
geezers in the only one there's a couple
of vailable but as you might see where
the title of his talk is by cuban at
ease so yeah we're just gonna talk about
you Mary today so it's open source it's
multi flared and it's designed to scale
so does this justice help with what
we're trying to achieve so we can scale
independently we can handle the failures
and we have automatic scaling so that
sounds like a plan to me so
especially for NDC because I know I've
well I don't know I felt like I need to
up my game as it's my first time here I
thought I build an demo especially for
NDC London so this is the Apple I've
created now look at my design skills
it is our front-end web application is
minimalistic it's beautiful and it's
welcoming so what happen is is that the
user would click get ticket and they get
redirected to this protesting screen so
this processing screen is connecting
violet via signaler and listening for
broadcast messages to a group the group
ID is is generated by a MongoDB in the
backend and then we have a worker role
which when it picks it up it will send a
message to a group to say that it's
completed the job and then it will
redirect that user to a video of people
clapping because I look I understand
it's in the afternoon and you don't want
to clap so I thought I'd get your phones
to do it for me
so let's just talk about containers
again for a sec so container is
essentially so we've got dotnet core in
there then we might have our app
settings and then we can have whatever
else we can have a cat in there everyone
because all I'm really concerned about
is container on the outside I'm just
concerned by the interface that I'm
connecting with so deploying up to in
kubernetes so here's our front-end
back-end and so on top of that we put
our low balances and also I'm in my demo
I'm using rubber mq as my message broker
and then I've also got a worker which
I've assigned to an auto scaling group
so here we go
keep an eye DS likes to name things
differently so instead of calling him
low balances we call them services and
we create a service for each part of
everyone so I just mentioned part now we
don't call them containers we call them
parts now what's the difference between
a pod and container a part can have
multiple containers I hope to give you
an example as to why you might want to
do that but it's usually common just to
have a one to one relationship and then
we have a horizontal part autoscaler as
well that's what we're going to use
today is HPA also a name of my favourite
beer but yeah our horizontal part of our
scaling
so lessons learned scaling in Cuba
nettleson so it does can I just get a
show of hands just for who knows bike
you Pilates or okay Coco that's half the
room great so for people who don't
necessarily know about keeping at ease
so what we call a machines we call them
nodes so and this could be a physical
machine obvious could be a virtual
machine so within here so we've got our
cube nineties layer a darker layer and
then we've got a virtual machine
available here so if you had to do this
manually you'd probably say right I'm
gonna put my application the red one is
our web app a container so we're gonna
put it there
and then because we know what we could
doing we're going to put another
container on another machine so that if
one machine fails you were covered and
we'll keep doing that and then we'll
just keep going up and up until we've
used up all our resource now at this
point why would you do I think I heard
someone whisper add more notes which was
absolutely correct well done and so then
we can start adding more containers onto
that too so you can also think of it as
a best Tetris player ever so I'd also
like to introduce you now to the master
node server Massa no discover kubernetes
slow going at that moment so that the
mass node is running the show and so
here's our favorite container again and
keeping at ease when we ask you
Panetta's deploy it then it decides
where it needs to go now so far I've had
the same container shape and size so how
not all containers on the scene so
that's why it's the best Tetris player
ever it can figure out the best places
to put it
and keep an eye users just essentially
arrest API so you can actually access it
by swagger so right here we go it's demo
time and I don't know where we're at
after running from a hotel so once I
quasi just say my screen
thank you yeah I lose a lot of time with
this I do apologize for anything that's
on my screens in the next moment I hope
I turn notifications off so that my mum
doesn't message me to say good luck
there we go marrow displays took me a
while great demo okay
um is there a couple of people in here
with access to this website at the
moment cool so if you got access to this
website if you could just turn your
phone on to sell it to eleven and go to
that URL so I don't have my laptop
connected to it so I'm gonna get ticket
here we go so we can now see the
processing so our new challenger
approaching that means that the work has
come online then it's processing ticket
received for some other challenges so I
hope there's some people there and oh
god okay that wasn't clapping and I
don't really want to watch Ringo - right
now so I can't hear anyone else at the
moment that well this is the issue
whilst that's happening I'll show you
why this one I hope yeah thank you thank
you thank you
so I'm keep color gap parts come on
internet yes there we go
so we'll get our deployments so what we
can see here is as a soccer fan so I've
got ten ticketing webs working I've got
one ticketing worker I got one API and a
now I've gotten some of my message
queue is that's a little bit concerning
anyway we'll plot on so there we go
again some more booze I'll try and
improve it
so let's yeah here's my Cuban at ease so
now I said my code isn't necessarily the
greatest so let's have a look so let's
have a look now worker so we'll go to
our deployment file so this is y amal if
you knew Tiamo it's a it can't be scary
and you can usually say bad things
towards it but you get used to after a
while so I can see here that I've got a
darker image
so then ticketing worker boo so that
might be potentially one of the images
one of the issues I've got so I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna change it to yay and
then I'm gonna apply it so I'm using a
cube color so we got some people here
who know Cuban at ease so does anyone
call cube cuddle differently in here
okay can stop booing so we got keep
everyone calls it something different
actually sorry the text is a little bit
small I do apologize if you can't see in
the back and please shout at me I'm here
to serve
umm so what I've done is that I've used
cube color so that connects to the API
and so what I've done is as I've said to
a to my Cuban areas close to that oh
there we go we got some clapping so it's
because I updated it to a cube cut' I'll
apply ticketing work at deployment I
updated that deployment llamo to go to
the ticketing worker yay which directs
you to the clapping now as we've heard
is happening sporadically and that's
because I've got this issue so everyone
can see that I've got one ticketing
worker here and like I said when I
mentioned about pods being able to have
multiple containers the two of two means
that I've got two containers running
with him and now within the code base
I've got a console application which
I've left purely as a console app and
then I've also got a simple web app to
create a metrics endpoint so a metrics
endpoint is just giving a very simple
text file that just says tickets and the
number of tickets currently in the queue
thank you sir god this might be a bad
idea
so now so we've seen how we can update
on Cuban artists and I just wanted to
show that for people who might not
necessarily know Cuban at ease and just
start to see some coding example so I
think the next place I want to go is to
scale up my cube now hustle so I've got
this file so let's have a look encode
for a sec so within here I've got to get
in here and I've got HPA so this is also
llamo file and I can send as many llamo
files as I want to keep it at ease and
they're declarative so there's lots of
different things I can happen and but in
within this fie the main thing to notice
by the HPA is that I've got minimum
number of replicas so that's a minimum
number of instances that I want of my
worker so this is declaring that I want
10 workers running at any one time the
maximum number of replicas is 20 now do
you know why you might want to have
maximum number of replicas yeah you got
money it could be taking up too much
resource it's yeah you got all those
issues and also about half an hour ago
you might have just overloaded your all
your notes and everything would have
crashed whilst you were doing a video -
so he knew you knew you had a backup
ready just in case so let's apply this
file and we'll also once we do this
we're going to watch what happens with
the parts so I'm gonna apply my
ticketing then we've got Q and then it's
HP so let me clear screen for you and
then cube cuddle get parts now this time
I'm gonna do it with - W which means
watch so we can see that hasn't happened
straight away and usually when you're
scaling with keeping at ease if you
scale with in your deployment files
you'll apply it and you don't expect to
see some to start happening HPA is a
little bit different and it's one of
these interesting scenarios as to why
one of the negatives of necessarily
using a cloud provider so cloud-hosted
kubernetes means that you don't have to
run it everything else sorry we can see
that can we can see the work is spinning
up now so the reason I like aks
personally is that I don't pay for my
master so the master is still on a node
which is still a virtual machine
or a computer so something I've got to
pay for so if you're with someone like
Amazon you're paying for that resource
if you will for sure you're not paying
for it now one of the issues with it is
is that with HP a the amount of times
that it slightly tracks it takes about
three minutes to update the scaling and
then also remember I've got a brain
freeze but when you have a look of
scaling we're getting back to it now so
there we go so if you have a look at
cube cuddle get parts now so we can see
that we got never for ticketing workers
running now rather than ask you all just
to go onto it what I'm going to do first
is I'm gonna do an a/b test I think
that's right so I'm currently sending 15
across up to count of 500 so whilst
that's happening I'll stick open up an
ever window just underneath it I've done
that no test on conference Wi-Fi so
whilst that's not working we got a
hundred requests now sorry I do
apologize for bouncing around a bit but
I mentioned the metrics that we had so
with kubernetes we can there's lots of
different ways that we can manage
scaling so like we can see CPU usage and
other things like that but if you wanna
have a custom metric then we need to
create on an API so what I can do is I
can do cube cuddle get raw and then I
can ask for the role because it's just
an API I can just ask of it so if we can
see on the bottom I've got 443 currently
in my message queue
so well I'll do again is I'll just check
again hopefully us we've gone down to
415 so again remember that we've got
currently ten workers running and
they're currently processing gross leads
now within our HPA I'll just execute for
a sec and I'll go back to code and have
a look at our HPA you can see here that
we've got a target average value of
three which is ridiculous in comparing
to that load so that's what it's trying
to achieve now what I've learned so far
with this is is that it doubles in size
so that's why I haven't gone and started
with one worker because doing this demo
here today it would have taken far too
long so let's have a look on the next
point
let's check us again cubicle get wrong
okay so we're down to three three six so
I've been trying to keep you occupied
for a moment whilst we've been doing
this so I'm get parts watch no so we're
still on ten so like I said about aks
it's because I don't have because I
can't manage my master then I don't get
to change the settings for the weight of
the time it takes to refresh view stats
but let's hope that some changes in a
couple of minutes it's always at this
point it's always a little bit nervous
as a speaker when you're just like come
on I've written you I trust in you yeah
okay there we go
hey I never thank you it was never in
doubt I never had that and never
happened so what's happened in this case
is Fadem I hate PA has noticed that our
average tickets a number is too high so
we need to add more workers to it now as
we had a min of ten and a max of 20 if I
close this so a little bit of an easy
way to see via number that we got going
on is by getting our deployments so we
can now see that we've gotten on the
bottom here we've got ticketing worker
as
20 20 20 20 great sir let's have a quick
look at IQ so we're down to 137 so
whilst that's happening I'm going to set
up a new screen so I'm gonna yeah create
such as a duplicate session yes so
you've been at ease let's make a little
bit bigger
that's code so it's cool that I'm just
showing you this well I think it's
called rest showing you've a sample and
that's returning me Jason and I can just
say that this is a value that's
available but what be better is is if we
could have an actual dashboard so let's
see if we can get that up and running
so if she is thank you so sorry I'm
still not very well um so that's yes so
what I'm gonna do is is that with this
command here I'm going to let me just
get that set up right so in the bottom
left here I'm passing this command so
I'm proxying the Prometheus data data to
my local host 1990 so now I buy it if I
go to localhost 1990 I'll be able to see
the data coming through so if I then
because I want to make it look nice I'm
gonna go to perf on it so I'm just gonna
export this for a sec there we go
right so now when I find one of my many
tabs did I go to the localhost 3000 so
I'm now able to access Ravana locally by
creating a proxy between myself my
cluster so on my dashboard I can click
new dashboard graph so I can just simply
so these are all these stats are coming
out from prometheus so Prometheus scans
these you can set how after it scrapes
it so we can see some of our demos there
again I can't hide my shame here I'll be
completely honest with you so this is a
moment I'll have to go to three hours
and let me get that oh right let's make
this easier for everyone to see so just
edit this and let's get rid of that
legend because we don't need that
what maximize it cool so this was a
moment I'll use my clicker so here's me
doing my demo in the hotel room just
before coming here and then he is where
it all crashed and it all started going
wrong and that's when I had the mad dash
to here so we've gone okay so far
so let's just make it a little bit
easier to see and let's change it down
to five minutes and we'll send across an
ever load test
so as I live it goes across this is
refreshing every five seconds so we
should start seeing some traction so
start a spike cool so let's just have a
quick look at how many pods we've got
going so yes we're currently running
twenty of twenty so we should be able to
see this go down now
now that we've warmed up this surface
I'd like to ask everyone here to open up
their laptops and phones and seven
monitor as loud as possible and I really
want to try and crush their conference
Wi-Fi so if if you wouldn't mind it'd be
greatly appreciated only because I can't
do this at home and it's so while starts
happening does anyone have any questions
they'd like to ask
it was first versus Gravano Gravano the
address are sorry sorry sorry my bad
a development squad calm just HTTPS
Devonian squad calm
so many windows there we go so whilst
this is happening I'd also just say that
cloud hosting is a great way to get
started I tried to do kubernetes a hard
way by EM so there's a talk that I saw
here last year by Alex Alison de Scott
Hanselman it was settin up a raspberry
pi cluster and I was in Cuban edges on
that so I thought it'd be a great way to
get started and it is and you learn
quickly why you'd like to actually give
it to someone else to manage right it's
cool
probably sooner than 500 should I I are
there we go we've got Sun coming in
so
so like we just made this a little bit
better than we did at the start of the
day when we just had a single worker
running this process and we've been able
to manage this get the scalability
without having to do anything else
Thank You Robin we've been able to do
the scalability without having to
intervene because we had the HPA there
that was constantly monitoring this sir
final point yeah we're just going to
update our deployments so I'm gonna go
you I'm going to I'm not in my directory
so I'll go there I got a good code so
has anyone heard of pub confía can I get
a yeah thank you so much interaction
today and right where am I going so I've
also got we've also got phone calls now
as well so I'm just gonna to play deploy
this ticketing worker so let's have a
look what's happening oh let me go to
another yeah that was a little bit
easier to see so we've just have cuban
at ease that we want to update an image
that's running on the pod so that we can
see some of the workers ver that they
aren't currently in a state of
terminating and pending service because
they've become aware that there's a
different image rack that should be
hosted so hopefully because I've only
just done this in the last hour as well
which might be why they've failed it
you're on so if you go to ticketing web
now
they are still going to do to that
moment too much let me just I know al to
make sure of this I'll take you out
speed
okay so I've to leave that worker and
I'm going to reapply
I hate deployment then in doing so
Roma sphere almost yes there we go we've
got some people with an out so we got
Eventbrite so there's some tickets still
left available for PubCon for tonight so
for tomorrow night and I'll be talking
about how we're actually living in a
zombie apocalypse and and so the title
is Shawn up a dev so yeah I think
there's some tickets still available so
if you want if you like to come along
it's a great way to meet some amazing
people and I'll be there and so it'd be
great to see there but on that point I'd
like to ask you the same questions I'll
just quickly floorboards cool well
thanks for your time any participation
and I hope you enjoy the rest of your
conference